get with the cloves are you kidding me that
man has done everything to keep his team in
it unbelievable you got to love ADV vintage
he goes wide pass in front what a save by
bton on lson highway robbery As Time runs
out and we go to a shootout just another
huge save by Jordan Bennington boy has heing
absolutely money here fantastic job by the
blues n minder chasing around this line and
now a quick snapshot rebounds there R gets
across and somehow makes the safe and ATI
Ron with his biggest saves of this contest
keeping Carolina in this one a little snow
angel action here to keep the canes oh mercy
ay down L leowski centers and a p save and then
another one on Pi another the rebound boy the
crowd here even loves that the home team turned
aside but Mark Andre showing the athleticism
that the people of Montreal have come to love
the back on the slot kov in and a kick sh by
FY unbelievable two bad stack you got to love
ADV vintage unbelievable stop for Mark Andre
flurry this side this time shot into the
rebound great save marks The Rebound in
front monstr kept it out somehow that he's
sprled back with the and swept it off the
line some of the fans behind the net thought
it was in play continues are you kidding me
he's back I think he's back glass give
and go Nyquist here's Yosi by grer what
a Dandy that might be the save of the year to
this point I know we're only a couple days in
Johnny but that was out standing Dynamite what
a [Applause] stop taken back for gets in front
and a shot rebound what a save by benington on
pelski he robbed him from 5 ft away absolute
robbery there by Jordan Bennington look at that
right there just love to see that from Jordan
Bennington two onone t get in Robertson what
a save incredible save by Bennington and the
game continues Dallas will get a power play
but how did they not score there on a two-on
one well I'll tell you how it's Jordan Benning
[Music] n driving on that what a save Campbell
the Scorpion Campbell a terrific stop look at
the Save By Campbell I mean that's incredible
that should have been in the back of the net
you'll see a blast at the short side Parson and
stopped twice by Campbell a third time by Jack
Campbell played out to keep it 61 parser right
now that disbelief on his face is cuz he can't
believe this Puck didn't find the back of the net
Ki gets it to Shay possible two on one gets
across oh Blackwood gets a glove to that
try on martinook robbing Martin pass shot and
martinook robbed by McKenzie Blackwood what a
save what a stop Martin I can't believe it slaven
with BOS slaven shot Sav by Blackwood it had been
a while but McKenzie Blackwood comes up with a
huge stop there on the odd Man attack 29th save
for Blackwood bar keeps the Pucket now sanheim in
front oh Demco on brink stayed right with it with
the left pad and it's still two nothing Demco gets
a break I mean he has kept them in this early in
the second the Flyers are two-on-one shorthanded
lton with Kates Kates lton getco with the gloves
are you kidding me that man has done everything
to keep his team in it ster Douglas what a stop
across the front of the net Laden thought he had
Deco down and out he had him down but in to the
glove it's played out in front open
man lightning and oh it's kept out
no the referee said it cross the line
I thought it was kept out on the diving
effort by Jacob trouba oh here's a great
look and no you know I don't think it's
in oh boy it's still touching the
red there I think trouba saved a
goal serves it up Tor is denied off the post oh
man he got his left p on one of those but look at
that save the first one the second one the left
pad oh he's been brilliant outstanding bang bang
here's Malin bouncing Pucket another glove save
by mazic mazic who's now the four four greedy
stops including this one on Riley Smith and now
across one timer save rebound stop two Tomkins
comes across with a right pad and I believe he
got a piece of that as well back to shoban AC
cross it goes hard shot there by SP for the save
made by Tomkins he leaves it for Nathan McKinnon
he'll shoot save rebound and Blackwood with his
best save of the night off kale Mar what a debut
for number 29 inal McKenzie Blackwood quick shot
save Martin rebound Troi and how did Martin grab
that one out standing stop on the rebound as
he got the glove on it and here's a rebound
opportunity tro cheek's going to settle it down
Martin you see him scramble he pushes pushes twice
cuts down the angle centering pass in front Oh
Martin moves laterally to make a big stop there
from Point Blank Range and he hears it from the
crowd outstanding stun out cook Fox sh again just
saved by inam what a save that was oh did he
reach out with the right leg R again and great
stop by Allen left hand to save the day this is
the end of a long shift puts the puck to an area
slips its way through and a pat saved by Allen
possible two onone eel joins Maro takes the shot
SP and go save by Gibson who fell about 8T to the
right of his net in doing so what stopped by John
Gibson right-handed shot Long Reach Gibson kind
of gave him that top corner and then just took it
away with the left hand Mar walks it in shot save
the rebound on net Stone Point Blank had a chance
and grow was there oh Mark Stone looks Skyward
he couldn't believe he missed that if he could
just Elevate that puck about six more inches that
was a sure fire goal and all of a sudden he get
two unbelievable chances oh the redirect the save
by should off the set up from L great opportunity
for zaka what a Le there by Soder Blom remember
that save if the Hawks are able to tie this one
up